now to an image the world has been
waiting to see you're looking at drone
video of the first grain ship to leave
ukraine since russia started its war
nearly six months ago it's a crucial
step in the worldwide fight against
hunger last year ukraine provided 10
percent of all the wheat in the world
but the world is the war is still raging
and there's a long way to go charlie
dagetta is in ukraine's port city of
odessa charlie good morning
good morning to you that ship left port
here on monday the russians have
blockaded portions invading in february
ukrainian authorities tell us there are
at least 16 more green ships stuck in
these ports waiting to leave
one ship may be a drop in the ocean of
ukraine's blockaded grain but it's a
start former rear admiral frederick
kenney jr among the team of
international inspectors who boarded in
istanbul the purpose of the inspection
was to ensure that the vessel was
carrying no unauthorized cargo or
personnel
just more than 26 000 tons of corn but
there are more than 20 million tons of
grain trapped in silos and ports in
ukraine desperately needed amid a
worsening global food crisis there's
been a lot of cooperative coordinated
effort by all parties and we'll keep
operating
that cooperation at sea has not been
replicated here on land
less than 24 hours after agreeing to
allow safe passage russian missiles
pounded the port city of odessa
military spokesperson natalia humanuke
said there is no such thing as trust in
russians
revealed that odessa had been targeted
by another missile overnight
russian forces have been bombarding the
nearby south coast city of mikalive in
the worst shelling since the war began
wheat fields have also been targeted
turning ukrainian farmers into
firefighters
but ukrainian forces are hitting back
with u.s supplied hymar systems able to
target ammunition depots and artillery
far behind russian front lines
yesterday president zielinski said one
cargo ship is nothing compared to what's
unfolding here saying the consequences
of this war are horrible not just for
ukraine but for the whole world
david
charlie dagetta in odessa ukraine thank
you charlie